the Joe Rogan experience you need to
connect with people you really need to
figure do you think the shit's gonna hit
the fan yeah I do
whoo yeah when how much time we have
well I'm at thought you had some
connections I'm gonna go north
okay I'm gonna go to some wooded area
yeah well you'll be fine I think the the
moon I think is gonna happen right now I
think I think you know based on some of
the things that I've kind of seen online
and you know that the chit chat and
hearing overhearing conversations with
with people that are you know part of
NASA and those kind of things and they
kind of go we've got 400 years and the
planets done whoa 400 years yeah so if
you think and you know for me I'm a by
plan right Bronner that means that if
it's if it's you know if we're not here
in 400 years or when's when does that
start well that started yesterday really
I mean when you think about it there's
natural resources and there's all those
things that start to kind of fall apart
and then we're disease to start showing
up and mm-hmm weird funguses that take
you out that didn't before well another
thing to think is we've only been human
for quarter million three hundred and
fifty thousand years whatever it is
there's gonna be something next yeah you
know whatever it is it's coming right
it's gonna be something that can survive
this so if this stuff can figure out how
to cool it so yeah it'll become so he's
freely it may it may be a huge a tree I
met a severely when I was seven years
old he's completely stable yeah for sure
who thinks the world's gonna end in 400
years
I'm such an idiot why did I say that out
loud that's a bad thing that's I don't
think the world's gonna end but I think
it's very likely the human beings will
be drastically diminished absolutely I
feel like that's I guess I should back
up that's my point the the thing that we
just are so arrogant about is that we're
somehow included in the future which is
not excluded where I not included well
I've been here for again 300 whatever a
thousand years right that's not that
long yeah you know I mean even
Neanderthals have half a million years
before us right so going back to now
though mm-hmm and us getting along now
and surviving better over the deck
a little bit going back to our like the
people talking to each other yeah how do
we you know how do we see this up
somebody can take it and not ruin it
with a reality TV show because they you
know that every reality TV show you see
it's been manipulated you know yeah
they'll they'll poke the person then
they know is going to blow up at some
point so that it causes drama and again
the dopamine dumping oh my god yeah
they're basically doing clickbait in
terms of how their programming the tone
right so how do we how do we make this
so that it's not an opportunity to make
a buck and to do that like a genuine
healing moment it can be done I think
it's got to be done online and it's got
to be done with no one involved other
than you and whoever you want to be
involved no advertising I mean that
doesn't even have to be you right but
whoever the person is right that that
facilitates this yeah but you just can't
have any producers you can't have
anybody with a vested interest in its
success okay it has to be done just
purely for the idea purely for the
exercise of getting people to
communicate that have disagreements and
realizing that so much of we know people
dig their heels in the sand and they
they want to be right more than they
want to be right you know more than they
want to get along and be harmonious with
each other right there's a there yeah
and I feel like that's yeah look I I
acknowledge that there's monsters in the
world there's [ __ ] monsters they're
in there in there in us we have no known
monsters inside of us there's other
monsters that have been nurtured over
years to to hate each other or hate
somebody else whatever there's that
nurturing you know nature versus nurture
monster I get that I'm talking about the
people that you can figure out a way to
like let's just let's figure this out
most of us yes most of us can figure out
a way to evil and most of us can go
south to most of us in the wrong
environment with the wrong people and
the wrong feelings and the wrong drugs
and the wrong jobs in the wrong
community we could be horrific neighbors
or getting the code button yeah or we
could be a part of a community